[Music]
house spacex builds rockets within a
week
spacex is probably the most ambitious of
all elon musk's endeavors ever
i know this is a serious claim since
we're talking of the men who made paypal
creating the fintech industry as we know
it the same man who's the boring company
is looking to create futuristic
underground tunnels for cars
the same man whose starlink satellites
are going to create low-latency
high-speed internet connectivity for all
but most importantly
high-speed internet connectivity that
won't give you coven 19.
and of course how can we forget tesla
which although not founded by mr musk is
the company that produces electric
high storage fast smart cars at an
unprecedented scale
so one might wonder why on earth elon
musk is still putting so much energy
into his space faring company spacex but
why on earth
would be the wrong question mr musk
wants to go to mars and
fast it's no wonder that his company
spacex has the capacity to build their
rockets in
under a week but that's not all keep
watching and we'll look at
all the pieces that have to fit to make
these one-week rockets a reality welcome
back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video
the first and most important aspect
responsible for the success
and speed of spacex is the man himself
elon musk mr musk came up with the idea
of spacex in 2002
as a way to provide cheap space
exploration he also has big dreams of
making humans an interplanetary species
in the case of any extinction event like
a meteor from outer space
or world war iii of course however time
is of the essence and musk knows this as
well
as he has commented in the past that we
need to speed up our rate of innovation
to be able to get to mars on time when
he says
on time we can understand that he means
before i die
because of this musk hires workers that
are absolutely enthusiastic about the
impact of their work on our species
and to be honest it's pretty wild if
your descendants can say that their
ancestor helped in making humans
multi-planetary when compared with say
nasa spacex has 6 000 employees with a
median age of 31 years while 56
of nasa's workforce is 50 years or older
spacex runs like a startup unlike nasa
where their employees are technically
working for the government
because of this nasa employees work the
regular 40 hours a week while spacex's
youthful workforce can stay up to 60 or
80 hours per week
sometimes spending as much as 100
voluntary work hours during critical
recoveries and launches
also with nasa being government owned
there is a lot of constraint on the
consistency of space exploration by the
country this is because the president
senate and policies change from time to
time as some congressmen and women will
be opposed to using taxpayer money to
fund what seems irrelevant
however at spacex musk is in charge and
has reliable investors who will pump
money into the company's projects
to make things even better for elon musk
spacex launches are extremely cheap in
comparison to other aeronautic companies
this is one of elon musk's primary
objectives for starting the company in
the first place
and there are several things making this
a possibility one is the cost of
materials that spacex have opted to use
in their new starship rockets
in the past like other aeronautic
companies spacex used carbon composite
to build rockets
however a change was observed when
citizens of boca chica began noticing a
structure they thought to be a water
tower prominent in the sky
spacex had begun using stainless steel
alloy for the design of its starship
vehicle
elon musk described the choice to go for
stainless steel over carbon composite in
an interview
he explained that carbon fiber costs 155
dollars per kilogram with 35 percent of
the material being lost in the
construction process
therefore actually making it as
expensive as 200
per kilogram in comparison stainless
steel alloy costs
dollars per kilogram elon musk has
described this as the best choice on the
rocket as 301 steel is not only cheaper
but is also more durable than carbon
composite or aluminum lithium in
cryogenic temperatures
the regular temperature in space nasa
spends around 2 billion
per launch compared to spacex's 62
million for its falcon 9 which reduces
to 50 million when being reused
with the innovation of 301 steel on
starship this figure is set to go even
lower
and speaking of reused this is also
another important factor as we have
already seen the figures
spacex strives to make all that
spacecraft reusable using hexagonal
silica fiber shield tiles
these shield tiles are useful because
re-entry into the earth's atmosphere
without them
would disintegrate and burn up the
spacecraft if you as a person were
re-entering into the atmosphere
you would probably appear as a tiny pink
coloration in the sky
and brighten up some kid's day who might
even make a wish on your remains
elon musk said that the hexagonal shape
of the tiles are perfect
and make it so that there is no straight
path for hot gas to accelerate through
the gaps
but beyond the materials that make the
process fast spacex also owns a south
texas region in boca chica
this is important because launching
rockets closer to the equator is optimal
this is why nasa and spacex have
launched sites in florida like cape
canaveral
the reason for this trend is that the
earth moves considerably faster at its
equator
1 670 kilometers per hour to be precise
if you were to launch a rocket halfway
between the equator and the poles it
would move at 1180 kilometers per hour
thus launching your rocket eastward in
the direction of the u.s rotation of the
equator would make you almost 500
kilometers per hour faster than the
other rocket launching halfway between
the equator and the poles
another major reason for the choice of
boca chica is the freedom it gives the
company
unlike other companies and even unlike
spacex's other operations in florida
california and texas
this location provides better logistics
for instance when getting ready to
launch a falcon 9
spacex first has to send the nine merlin
engines from hawthorne california to
mcgregor texas for testing
it is then sent back to hawthorne where
it is attached to the falcon heavy
and trucked over to kennedy space center
in florida 2500 miles away for testing
this trucking process is done with 44
wheelers from bale brothers and eze
trucking
and the space ship is even modified to
fit on roads and under bridges
although this process requires a lot of
movement money and time
spacex still managed to pull off 26
successful falcon 9 tests in 2020
however with bokuchika the construction
site testing site
and launch site are all in one place
cutting out a lot of work that would
have already been done relatively
quickly by musk and his brilliant team
the few people living in boca chica have
had their houses bought from them for
triple its market valuation as musk
plans to build a city suited to the
needs of the project that will take us
to mars
spacex has also purchased more land
beyond boko chica and plans to call the
entire city
star base pretty cool however some
residents of boca chica have refused to
sell their homes
and that's a pretty unique experience
unlike regular people who have to put up
with their neighbors kids banned or
something
these guys have neighbors that play
heavy metal but seriously this new
launch site has improved a lot as spacex
and elon musk have already run
four high-altitude flight tests for its
starship in boca chica from february to
may
they include sn9 sn10 sn11
and sn15 five tests if we're counting
the snl
show hosted by mr musk in may which was
also the most popular
and this is part of spacex's secret for
success not the shows the rapid testing
they employ this unique way of not
relying too much on computational models
but rather on empirical data from their
test flights
this is why they are expecting maybe
even hoping to see faults when they run
these tests these rapid tests are made
possible by the cheapness of each launch
which is also boosted by the rate and
reliability of investment
as well as the fact that the company is
run by elon musk not a government whose
wavering policies
may influence the speed of development
the space race is getting hotter by the
day
this time not between russia and the usa
but recently between spacex and blue
origin
musk and bezos in no time we'd be on our
way to mars making a new civilization
and becoming the extraterrestrial life
we've always hoped for
i personally just want to see elon musk
and jeff bezos hopefully gather their
space fleet and duke it out in space one
day
how long do you think it will be before
we get a civilization on mars
more importantly who do you think would
win in a star wars between jeff bezos
and elon musk
let us know in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video make sure to give
it a like and check out more awesome
ones on the simply tech channel thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
you